Okay.
So last time we were talking about
exponents and how statistics gives rise to
them. And we looked last time
that the Boltzmann factor,
that e to the minus h over our
tea or Delta h over our tea,
which tells you the, uh, the temperature
dependence of the equilibrium constant.
It gives you the equilibrium constant.
You mean remember at room temperature,
three fourths, a Delta, h
and kilocalories, right.
And we saw last time that that comes
from counting arrangements of a fixed
number of energy bits. And the
important thing is that they're random,
that all of them are equally likely.
Let's see, I get to get there. Okay.
Uh, that has interesting
philosophical implications.
I think you remember at the start of the
course we were talking about types of
authority. Uh, and in
particular, I remember in Hamlet,
a act five scene too.
He says there's a divinity
that shapes our ends.
So this was a traditional view in society.
But then this guy came along in 1851,
you might know who that is,
Charles Darwin with the
origin of the species.
So there was conflict between the
religious fundamentalists and Darwin's
Darwinists that continues to this day.
But I think they really missed the point
because Darwin had the idea that things
were developing and getting better all
the time, right? So there's a certain,
uh, compatibility between that and the
sensibilities of the fundamentalist,
but also not too long from them.
This guy came along Boltzmann and he said,
everything is driven just by randomness.
There's no goal for everything that
should be the real conflict between
religious fundamentalists
in science is Boltzmann.
But so few people understand what
Boltzmann did that there's no, uh,
reason for the conflict.
At any rate,
we saw where the Boltzmann factor
came from in terms of statistics.
Then there's the entropy factor,
which we saw last time.
And notice that as I've written it
here in the top, the top equation,
the one with Boltzmann, there's an
r and the one on the bottom has a k.
Sometimes you see ours
and sometimes seem ks.
They're actually the same thing thatK is,
if you measure the energy
per molecule and are,
is if you measure the energy per mole.
So all you have is Avogadro's number
is included in one of them and not the
other. They're really the same thing,
these two exponentials. But at any rate,
we can cancel the teas and know that that
e to the s over k is accounting number
w the number of molecular
structures being grouped.
And we saw that at the end of the last
time in terms of Gauche versus anti
butane.
And remember that s equals log k,
which is the same equation,
just the on each side
is on Boltzmann's tomb.
Uh, but let's look at one more
example in terms of cyclohexane.
You remember the Cyclohexane con farmers?
I need to turn this light out and this
one on there. That one's on. Okay.
Remember the cyclohexane con farmers.
If it's a chair,
it's very rigid. Why
is it rigid? Remember,
why is it hard to twist with
respect to the molecular model?
Why is it hard to twist?
Eric?
What ma?
Why does this particular model in which
rotation around bonds is completely free?
Why is it hard to rotate, to go
like this? Why is there a click?
Pardon me.
Oh, it's the, it's the bending angle
that has to flatten out when you do this.
Remember we talked about that. But
anyhow, this one is very rigid,
but if you click it into the boat,
then it's actually a twist boat that
turns to all sorts of structures ever so
easily.
So there are many more accessible
structures for a boat than there are for a
chair. The chair, you have
this one and you have this one,
right? But for a boat or a twisted or
the flexible form, as it's often called,
you have lots and lots
of accessible structures.
What's that going to
mean in terms of entropy?
That there are many more structures.
You're going to account
for the flexible form,
then you count for the chair
form the rigid form. Okay.
So if we look at, this is a picture
of the, of the energy with the,
the chair at the minimum of energy.
The twist boat is five and
a half kilocalories above,
but it has very small barriers
among different twists, boat forms.
So we would say there are few
structures that are Cyclo that our chair
cyclohexane,
but many structures that are the boat.
And furthermore, if we look at
it in terms of quantum mechanics,
which is the real way to do it,
we noticed that when there's a steep,
stiff valley, there are very few
energy levels that are accessible,
right? But if the, if the barriers
are low, then there are many,
many quantum levels.
So you count many more quantum levels
for the flexible form than you do for the
chair form.
What that means is from whether they're
red classical view or the green quantum
view, there's a big statistical
factor and entropy factor,
which turns out to be about seven fold
favoring the twist boat over the chair.
The chair is still favored.
It's favored because of
energy that Boltzmann factor
III to the delta h over t,
but this reduces that bias in favor of
the by witches would otherwise be 10 to
the three fourths of 5.5 right?
It reduces it by about a factor of 2000
so the equilibrium constant is only
14,000 instead of 14,000.
It reduces it by a factor of
seven to make it 2000. Okay,
so that's,
but so we've been talking about
entropy here in statistical terms,
but remember earlier we talked about
the fact that physical chemists actually
measure entropy is something experimental,
not just accounting exercise.
Uh, and they do it beginning
with something that's as
close as possible to zero
Kelvin. Because if you have a perfectly
ordered crystal at zero Kelvin,
then there's only one structure
you're talking about, right?
So the entropy is the log of one,
which is zero or log of
one over r times R. Okay?
So it's zero or, but then
as you warm it up, you,
you, you put, as you put heat in,
you measure the increase in this thing
called entropy by how much heat you put
in at each temperature as you warm up.
And we talked about that already.
And you'll notice how qualitatively how
this works is that floppy molecules like
the flexible form of cyclohexane that
have many closely spaced energy levels
absorb more energy and they absorb it
at lower temperatures and thus they have
more entropy when they get warmed.
So whether you do it experimentally by
measuring the heat that gets absorbed or
whether you measure it by
counting quantum states,
you get the same result that a floppy
molecule is favored. In terms of entropy,
we talked about that too when we were
talking about the barrier to ethane
rotation.
Okay,
so we've looked at the Boltzmann factor
and this entropy factor that come from
counting, noticed it in the second
case where truly we should be counting,
not structures but quantum states.
How many states are there that count and
if you want to be really, really picky,
you say the weighted number of quantum
states cause ones that are higher in
energy or not as populated as
ones that are lower in energy,
but we don't have to worry about that.
Now at any rate,
those two factors taken together are
what gives the equilibrium constants,
which was we said before is is uh,
e to the minus Delta g free energy.
That means it's both an vow be heat
and entropy, this counting thing,
but there's more to it than that.
There's also the statistics involved in
the law of mass action and that comes
from counting molecules per
volume that is concentration.
So you can count energy,
you can count quantum states and
you can count molecules per volume.
This is very easily understood.
The way it developed experimentally is
that in the late 17 hundreds there was an
attempt to assemble a hierarchy of
affinities that some elements had more
affinity than others.
So if you had a compound that involve
one element and mixed it with an element
that had higher affinity,
that one with higher affinity would take
away molecules from the one with lower
affinity.
But then it was found in the early 18
hundreds that it's doesn't always go in
that direction because concentrations
can change and make things go the wrong
way towards something
that's a very low affinity.
If it has very high concentration and
by the middle 18 hundreds this was
formulated as an equilibrium constant
k which was understood as the balance
between forward reactions
and reverse reactions.
You've seen that k one over k minus
one is the big equilibrium constant.
So concentration comes into it in this
thing called the law of mass action.
If you have two ways that can go to a two,
then you have this equilibrium constant
written as the concentration of a two
divided by the concentration of a squared.
Now why the exponent?
Where does that exponent to come from?
And sometimes it's three. Remember again,
it's statistical and very, very
easy to see. Here I used the uh,
Xcel to place a bunch of circles
randomly on a two dimensional plot.
So it put 50 of these circles down and
we're going to count as dimers things
where they overlap, where they
touch one another. Okay? So there's,
if you have 50 particles,
this particular realization
of randomness gave one dimer,
but suppose we add another 50 right
now in addition to the original dimer,
there are eight more.
Okay?
And now suppose I add another 50 now
there are 19 dimers or another 50 now
they're 35 dimers or another
50 and now they're 59 dimers.
Now let's make a plot of how many
dimers there are compared to how many
particles there are.
Undying one.
So there's a number of particles and the
number of dimers plotted the data there
and you see what it is.
It's a parabola that the number of diapers
is proportional to the square of the
number of monomers. Now
why should that be? So
it's because as you
increase the concentration,
you increase the number of units there.
Obviously that's by definition,
but you also increase the fraction of
the units that have a near neighbor that
are touching. So not only do you
increase the number that could be dimers,
you increase the fraction that are dimers.
So there are two ways in which increasing
the concentration increases the dimer,
right? So it's a square. That's
where the exponent comes in.
It's purely statistical
for random distribution.
And then of course an energy can
enter in entropy can enter in.
That will change the k.
But the but the,
but the exponent on p right is due
just to this accounting procedure.
So you increase both the number
and the fraction that are dimers.
Okay. So now we know about equilibrium
statistics and exponents. Uh,
we have particle distribution,
that's the law of mass action.
That's that square we just talked about.
We have energy distribution,
Delta h,
the Boltzmann factor,
and we have counting of quantum
states, which has to do with with, uh,
entropy.
Okay,
so free energy determines what
equilibrium is. What can happen,
right? And that Delta g remember,
includes both entropy and energy,
but it doesn't tell you at all
how quickly it will happen,
what the kinetics of the reaction
are. So we'd, for that purpose,
we're going to try visualizing reactions
to see if we can get a picture of what
determines rates. And we're going
to look at two kinds of things.
We're going to look at classical
trajectories and at the potential energy
surface and collective concepts.
So first,
let's start with the
potential energy surface.
Here's a very simple
It's just the two dimensional diagram.
So we've seen it before.
We plot the distance
between two atoms, a, B,
and the potential energy as
a function of the distance.
So this is a more type curve. Uh, okay.
So we put a ball on it and let that ball
roll to map out different distances is
it moves.
That's the horizontal axis and the
energy corresponding to that distance.
So it rolls back and forth,
right?
Mapping out the change in geometry
horizontally and the change in energy
vertically. Now we're gonna look
at a three dimensional surface,
or actually two geometrical dimensions
plus the third dimension coming out at
you.
The contours have to do with potential
energy of three particles now,
but in order to describe the
position to three particles,
you need three distances, one to two,
two to three and three to one, right?
So that's too many
dimensions to plot this way.
So we're going to assume
that they're all on a line.
So we only have the distance between
one and two and the distance between two
and three.
So two coordinates will tell you what
the arrangement of those three atoms are,
if, if they're in just one
dimension. Okay? So linear,
try atomic ABC.
On the horizontal distance,
we have the distance a to B
on the vertical axis, axis
B to c, and the contours.
Tell us how low the energy is. The
darker the lower the energy. Okay.
Uh, so, uh, this specifies the structure.
So the position of a specifies
not the position of an Adam,
but the position of a set of Adams,
right? So as we move one point around,
we're moving to Adams are
changing to distances,
but we can denote it with one point
here into geometric dimensions. Okay.
So let's look at several regions.
Let's look at that valley on the right.
What is that valley? What does,
when the point is in that valley,
what's it describing?
It says that the distance
between a and B is large, right?
So a, as far away from B, what
does it say about the BC distance?
It's short.
It's the normal distance for IBC molecule.
So what is it when a point is in that
valley, what geometry is it describing?
It's describing a BC molecule with an
a Adam at a great distance from it.
Depending on how far
out we go to the right.
Does everybody see that one position
of the point tells us where both all,
where all three atoms are, as long
as they're on a line. Okay. Now,
how about up there on that plateau?
What's happening there?
What's the physical system?
Maria, what do you say?
Yeah, the atoms are all
separate from one another.
Be is c as far from B and a as far from B.
So there are,
the atoms are separated
and it's high in energy.
You're not surprised that it
takes energy to pull them apart.
And there is a cliff, right?
If this were a hiking map,
that would be a cliff. What does that
cliff mean? Why is there a cliff there?
Okay,
Greg,
what do you say?
Why is there a cliff shown there?
What's the geometry that,
that that points in that region described?
Yeah.
What's close together is a close to be
a close to be.
I couldn't hear no,
here's the distance ab it's way out
there where that cliff is. Right?
So a is far away,
but what's happening,
B and c are getting very
close to one another,
so that's a collision between B and c
much shorter than their bond distance.
Right there being scrunched together in
that region and that's why the energy
goes up very rapidly because they're
running into one another closer than they
liked to be.
There's a ridge right
as you go down there.
If you are hiking,
that would be a ridge and there's a
special point on the ridge which is marked
by the Red Cross. What would you
call that if you were hiking,
if you are in this yet,
the valley that's labeled yellow and
you were thinking of getting the other
valley, what would you call
that cross if you are hiking,
not a peak, right? It comes,
he gets high as it gets close to me here
and it gets high out on the plateau.
It's actually low as we go along the line,
but it's high as we go to the line. What
would you call that if you were hiking?
Some of you must hike.
Pardon me?
It's a pass between one valley.
On the other valley.
That's the way you would go
if you were hiking. Right?
So you don't have to climb so high.
Okay,
so it's a pass or in chemistry we call
it a transition state or a transition
structure and it's like a potato chip,
right?
It's a minimum in one
direction along the ridge,
but it's a maximum in the aisle in the
path between the two valleys. Okay,
so that's a very special point. Okay.
Now let's look at this a little closer.
Suppose we sliced the surface.
We took a knife and slice that along
the red line there horizontally and then
folded it back to look at
the cross section. Does
everybody see what I'm saying?
What would the cross section look like?
It's exactly that one we looked at before.
So that involves stretching a and B
with c so far away that it's irrelevant,
right? So it's just stretching a
diatomic molecule or if we sliced,
so that's vibration of Ab with
the distant spectator of c.
Okay. Now suppose we sliced it that
way and folded back. Now what is it?
All right,
it's a vibrating BC
molecule with a far away,
right? So again, by
choosing points on this,
we can describe any geometry of these
three points we want as long as they're on
a line.
But a single point is a whole structure.
Okay?
Now let's look at a trajectory.
We roll a ball on this surface
and it rolls up toward the past,
but it doesn't make it
and comes back like that.
So that's a trajectory
that was unreactive.
It didn't make it into the product of
alley, it didn't get across the ridge.
And physically what it means is that a
gets closer to BC while BC is vibrating,
it's moving up and down,
right?
So BC is vibrating a comes in
and then bounces off again,
right?
So it was an unsuccessful attempt
of a to take be away from C
or suppose we do this one,
hey approaches and now see
flies away from vibrating ab.
Does everybody see that? Want
me to say it again? Right?
So as it comes along, B and c are standing
still. It's not moving vertically,
right? So the BNC or at
their normal distance, their
standard distance a comes in,
Watson into it, gets really
close, runs into that cliff,
really close to be. This
is the distance Ab, right?
And then it starts a B is vibrating and
see as getting far away as it goes down
the product valley.
So that's a reactive trajectory where the
first trajectory was unreactive notice
that this is classical rolling a marble
on the thing because a was approaching a
non vibrating BC.
We know from quantum mechanics that
BC can't just sit there, BC vibrates.
So that's not a realistic trajectory.
It's a classical model of a
quantum mechanical system.
Now people have made surfaces like
that for real systems like h three one
hydrogen atom attacking a
hydrogen molecule and taking
one of the hydrogens away.
Here it is.
This was drawn.
This is the first surface that
was drawn that I know of, uh,
by Henry ironing at Princeton in 1935
and it had some that has crazy angles.
And the reason it has that angle is so
that a marble rolling on it will behave
according to the way the masses of the
thing so that the kinetics kinematics are
exactly right. So that it really
does do the proper classical thing.
If you roll a marble on here, it will
trace Newton's laws of motion for this.
Uh, this, uh, h three system.
One thing that's unrealistic about it is
that there's a minimum at the near the
transition state.
There's a little lake up there that's
just an artifact that came from the
equation. He used to approximate
the surface. It's not real.
There actually is a potato chip,
not a lake up there at the past.
Some people have called it lake ironing.
Okay.
But here's a more
complicated surface that was,
it says it was done by c par in
his Phd thesis at Cal Tech In 1969.
This is for h h br.
Again linear but hydrogen atom attacking
Hbr to take away it's hydrogen.
And this,
this describes the construction of a
model based on that surface and actual
physical model on which you can
roll marbles. Right? So here it is.
And then the dimensions,
that one inch corresponds to 1.4
inches is an angst drum and so on.
So they actually constructed physical
models to do this. And as it happens,
we have that physical model here.
Uh
Oh here.
Yeah,
right.
This is it. And let's see,
I've got to change the
excellent.
Okay. And we have some marbles. So
notice what's different about this one.
Here's, I'll hold it up so you can
see it. There's the surface, right?
And here's a crow, a
slice through one, right?
That's h two with this
valley is h two with the BR.
Adam. This valley is
HBR with an h at, right?
So we can try rolling balls
and see what happens here.
Okay.
So here I am far away the h
atom as far away from Hbr.
And I do that and it's vibrating,
but it doesn't succeed. Right?
I can do it a little bit more.
Most reactions aren't,
aren't, uh, successful.
Oh, hellos. All right.
And is it comes out,
it may be vibrating when it comes out
or it may not be vibrating when it goes,
Ooh. What's the, what's the cross?
The cross is that transition structure,
right? Or the transition state.
Yeah.
Right. So the, so you could
do every possible trajectory.
You could have different velocities at
which a is colliding with BC and you can
have different, uh, amounts of vibration
and different phases of vibration.
I could start it going this way,
or I can start it going this way.
And if I did every possible one of those,
then I could average over all of them
and see how many of them succeeded.
Right. In reaction. And that would allow
me to predict the rate of this process.
We'll turn off the wrong light.
Okay.
So people have done that kind of thing.
But studying lots of random
trajectories provides too much detail.
No one really cares about all
those individual trajectories.
What you care about is
what fraction succeed.
And if you could do that in a simpler
way than rolling it a zillion times and
averaging,
then that would be a better approach.
So it's better to summarize this thing
statistically using collective terms,
not individual pads,
but collective terms such
as enthalpy and entropy.
And you can do it in this way.
Okay?
You have a steepest
descent path from the past.
Suppose you slice this surface with a
knife perpendicular to the screen along
that path and then fold it out to make
it flat and look at the Cross section of
it. Okay? And now we'll tip
it up and it looks like that.
Does everybody see how it looks like that?
Hey,
we sliced along the path that goes
up over the transition state. Okay,
so we have potential energy as a
function of distance along the reaction
coordinate. But of course we're trying to
summarize a whole bunch of things here,
not nothing roles exactly along that path,
right?
So we're going to lose some of
the specificity of the reaction.
Coordinate by grouping things.
We're not going to take a trajectory,
but a sequence of three species.
The first species is
the starting material.
The second species is the transition state
and the third species is the product.
And now instead of having an explicit
meaning for every geometry along that
path, what we're going to do is associate
each of those starting materials,
transition state and products with a
certain end therapy and a certain entropy
that is a certain free energy.
So we have instead we're going to plot
free energy vertically, incorporate,
uh,
incorporate entropy as that is how loose
these things are as well as an therapy,
their energy. And now we just
have three values of free energy,
the free energy of the starting material,
three energy,
the transition state free energy of
the product. And now we can use those.
And so, but we've lost a
lot of specificity in what
the reaction coordinate is.
It's just a sequence.
Now have three species,
but we can now use free energy
to determine what can happen.
We already could do that.
But how rapidly,
and you do that with the theory that I
already made up when he drew that surface
at 1935 called transition state theory.
You assume that the rate constant,
and we talked about this before in
units per second, is 10 to the 13th.
So it had things happen 10 to the 13th
per second times the concentration of the
transition state.
So the idea is that things that are in
the transition state are moving at the
rate 10 to the 13th per second.
So if you know how many are
at the transition state,
then you know how many are
going to product 10 to the
13th times that per second,
right? And you know how to do an
equilibrium. We already do that.
All we do is use that special double
dagger to mean that the two mean the
transition,
the difference in energy going from
the starting material to the transition
state,
the difference in free energy.
Now we can calculate that
equilibrium constant.
If we know how much starting material
there is the law of mass action,
we know how much transition that state
there is an equilibrium with that
starting material,
right?
So that e to the minus Delta g over rt
is the equilibrium constant for getting
the transition state. Multiply it by the
concentration of the starting material.
You have the concentration
of the transition state,
multiply it by 10 to the 13th and
you know how fast it's going. Right?
So it assumes that there's a universal
rate constant for transition states going
to the product 10 to the 13th per second.
That's about how fast things vibrate.
So things won't stay on the
potato chip there roll off.
And the rate at which they roll
off is 10 to the 13th per second.
This is of course an approximation.
It isn't correct because there's not
true equilibrium between the transition
state in the starting
material for true equilibrium,
the same number must be going in and out,
right?
But when things get to the transition
state, often they keep going.
They don't come back. So it's not really
a rigorous theory, but it's a very,
very helpful theory for
approximate purposes.
And that's what I say here.
Okay,
so using energies to predict
equilibria and rates for one step,
reactions free radical Halogen Asians,
and let me look,
we do have time to go through this stuff.
I think at least most of it,
we've already seen this,
that you break a chlorine atom into to
chlorine molecule into two Adams than you
do single electron,
curved arrows,
take the hydrogen away from methyl
from methane to give methyl,
and then it attacks chlorine.
We seen this before and the chlorine,
Adam comes back to constitute
a chain reaction. Okay,
so it's catalytic and radical.
Okay,
now we break and make bonds in this.
So we've already seen average
bond energies that might
tell us how hard it is to
break a bond, right? If,
if that's what we have to do
to get to the transition state.
So we may be on the way
to get getting rates,
but are these average bond energies,
real bond energies or are they
just a trick for reckoning?
The nth Albi,
the total energy heat of formation
or whatever of a particular molecule.
And we talked about this before and
saw that mostly it is a trick that
individual bond energies change,
right?
So average bond energies are not what
you want to use for this purpose,
although they might be in the
ballpark of the right numbers.
But they're not the right numbers.
What you really need. Our Bond,
dissociation energies, the actual energy
it takes to break a specific bond.
And we've talked about how you
could get that from spectroscopy.
Those are real.
The average bond energies are just a
way of calculating molecular energy.
So appendix two of the straight
razor and Hedgecock book, uh,
shows various specific bonds between the
groups in column a and the Adams in or,
or groups in, in a row, a,
they're in the top row.
And those were the best value.
Those were when that book was published.
The best values as of 2003 are a little
bit changed from that and were tabulated
by Barney Ellison, who's picture
I showed you time before last.
So here's a table from Blacksburg and
Ellison that shows a bunch of these things
and how well they're known.
The H two bond association
energy as 104.206 plus or
minus 0.03 kilocalories per
mole. So it's very well known.
So some of them are very,
very well known and some of them
are known only approximately.
Let's look at a few of
them. Uh, so h two 104.2 HF,
136 HCL, 103 Hbr, 87, Hii,
71. So as you go down the halogens,
the bonds get weaker and weaker.
Why should that be?
Why do larger halogens give weaker bonds?
It's because they have poorer overlap
with hydrogen because at normal bond
distances,
because their orals are very diffuse,
they don't have high numbers
where the in the region,
where the hydrogen is and you
have the electron, the uh,
energy match also is unfavorable.
So if you have h f with good
overlap and a very low f,
then you get lots of stabilization.
Those,
some of those two red arrows as
big a strong bond. And if it's Ahi,
there's the overlap isn't so good
and the energy match is uh, is,
is better but,
but still the amount by
which the electrons go down
is not as much as with Hf.
So we can see qualitatively why that is.
So less electron stabilization
means a week or bond.
And we're going to talk about
this more next semester.
This is just to give you a flavor of it.
And you hear in the table too,
we see there's the same trend in bonding
with methyl groups that the halogen
methyl,
the fluorine methyl bond is 115 but the
fluorine or but the IOD and methyl bond
is only 58.
And,
but if you go across hydrogen
with the different Al,
Kiehl's methyl, ethyl, propyl,
t beautiful,
they're all very close to a hundred
kilocalories per mole but not the same.
And that will turn out to make an x a
difference as we'll see next summit early
next semester.
And if you look at some of the other
kinds of radicals you see there are
differences there. Special
cases for vinyl. Allie, ill
remember Alli allow alcohol,
uh,
fennel and Benzel and uh,
I'll show you just a
little bit about that.
Are these unusual bond associate bond
association energy values due to unusual
bonds or unusual radicals?
That is standard. We have, here's the
starting material, here's the bond,
here's the product. Is
the bonds broken, right?
For making the radicals so we can
get a strong bond either by lowering,
by making the bond strong,
or by making the radicals bad.
Either way increases the
barrier, right? Similarly,
we can make a small one either by making
the bond week or making the radical
stable. Is this something that is
meaningful to talk about? Well,
let's look at it in the
case of these special cases.
So vinyl you see is 110
kilocalories per mole. It's, uh,
the, the bond to age. So
it's a very strong bond.
Why is there something special
about the vinyl radical?
There's no special stabilization.
There's no overlap between
that singly occupied orbital,
which is a sigma orbital and the
double bond, which is a Pi orbital.
There's nothing especially
stable about the vinyl radical.
But if you look at the bond in the
starting material, the Ch bond,
it has sp squared hybridization of the
carbon. So that one's a strong bond.
That one's hard to break because
the bond is unusually strong,
not because the radicals are
unusually unstable. Okay.
Or if you look at a fennel,
it's the same deal.
You have a sigma Somo and the Pi Bonds,
the low lumos that might stabilize that
singly occupied orbitals electron are
perpendicular orthogonal to it. So
again, it's hard to break that bond.
On the other hand, the allium,
and remember Alli allow alcohol.
We were talking about here's an elk
keel radical. Now there's overlap.
Pi Overlap between the SOMO
and the Pi Star in the pie.
It turns out, and we'll talk about
this more next time, that that,
that when you mix those two,
the Pi Star on the left on the
right and the Somo in the middle,
you get stabilization,
you'd get the same stabilization
by mixing the pie with the Somo.
And if you mix both of them with the Somo,
you get that structure.
But this isn't the time to talk about
that. But at any rate, the normal,
the starting bond is normal.
It's an s p cubed ch bond and normal bond.
But in this case,
the radical is unusually stable.
So it's easy to break that
one 10 kilocalories easier
than for normal ch bonds.
And the same for Benzel. Okay. Now,
possibility of how of
doing a halogenation.
Let's look first from the point of view
of the equilibrium constant from this at
the difference in energy between
starting material and product.
So we look at what bonds are
broken and what bonds are formed.
The red bonds are broken,
the green bonds are formed.
So there'll be a cost for breaking the
red bonds and there'll be a return for
making the green bonds. And
let's see how big it is. Okay,
we're going to do it for fluorine and
chlorine, bromine, and iodine. Okay?
In every case, we're breaking a
ch bond 105 kilocalories per mole,
and we're breaking a halogen halogen bond.
But those are different
for the different halogens,
although interestingly not monotonic, it's
not as smoothly as smooth progression.
It goes up and then down again.
And the cost is the sum of those two.
What it's gonna cost to break those bonds.
How about making bonds?
We're going to make the CX bond and
we're going to make the HX bond.
So the returns will be that.
And now we see whether we
could make a living doing this.
What will the profit be?
Right?
So in the case of fluorine to 51 is much
greater than the cost of one 42 so it's
a big energy. It's really
exothermic, right? Chlorine,
it's only 19 bromine is only nine and
I had done is minus 12 what does that
mean? It means you can't do
this reaction with iodine.
The equilibrium advised
in the wrong direction.
Okay,
so already that,
that the equilibrium constant and how
energy relates to it tells you that
something is impossible to do,
but the others seem to be possible.
But will they happen?
How fast will they be?
Do you have to wait until the end of the
universe in order for this to happen?
Well, let's look at that. How the rate,
which will depend on the mechanism,
the equilibrium constant,
it doesn't depend on the path,
it's just how high the starting
material is and how high the product is.
But how fast you get depends on
the barriers you have to go across.
So let's suppose let's just
try breaking two bonds,
changing partners and forming two bonds.
Okay?
Then we have to get to the barrier.
We have to break to bonds.
So those that costs we're going to have
to spend in order to get to the barrier.
So is this a plausible mechanism?
How fast would the reaction
be if we use that mechanism?
Well at room temperature,
say 300 Kelvin,
then it's 10 to the three fourths
of how high it is to get there.
Then Times 10 to the 13th per second.
But notice that tend to the 13th times
10 to the minus one oh six which is three
fourths of 142 is 10 to
the minus 93 per second.
10 to the 93 seconds is a long, long time.
I don't know how old the universe is,
but I suspect that's longer. Right.
So what about this mechanism?
Plausible implausible.
How could you make it happen?
Shy.
Pardon me?
Change the temperature because we can
change that three fourths to something
else by to the much smaller number
by increasing the temperature.
So no way to do that one.
But if we go to 3000 Kelvin,
then it's 10 then it's
250 reactions per second.
So that's quite feasible.
As long as nothing else happens,
something else might be even faster,
right?
But at least this mechanism could
work if you were in a flame,
say or in Professor Chupp because
oven that we talked about last time.
Okay,
now let's look at IRA's h plus h two here.
So we want to get from this valley
to the other valley. How do we do it?
This mechanism would be to break a
bond and then so dissociation and then
association, but a, it's very
slow to get up there, right?
To get up to that plateau
of breaking a bond.
There's a much easier way to get from
one valley to the other. What is it?
Go through the past,
right?
So instead of doing that slow reaction,
you can do this much faster reaction
making a new bond as you break the old one
so you don't have to pay all the cost of
breaking the old one and you're getting
something back for it.
So you can have a free radical chain
substitution where you have an x Adam,
and we've talked about this before,
take the Hoa from our than the r group.
Takes away x from x to,
and it can just go round and round.
There's this machine very much like the
machine that professor Sharpless talked
about that goes round and round.
You feed in starting material and
the products come out and you don't,
it's a catalyst.
You don't have to go to such high
energies as you normally would have to do.
Uh,
so the possibility of halogenation here,
we looked at it that
equilibrium and saw that,
forget it with I and the others look okay
and w four mechanisms with reasonable
rate,
we could change those two columns,
exchange them so that we make
the Hx as we break c h three h.
So x, Adam helps you do that. And
that generates then a ch three group,
which helps the reaction on the right.
So now step one,
how much energy do you
have to put in your,
you're paying 105 but you're
getting back a 136 so that's great,
right? The first step is,
is seems plausible. Now,
although you don't know how high the
barrier is that you have to get from
starting material to product. But at
least it's much easier. So the top one,
it looks good all around the chlorine
and bromine will be a little touchy on
those first two steps because
there uphill and energy.
But, but step two is
good in all cases. Okay?
So what we need to do is be able
to predict activation energy.
But Rome wasn't built in a day.
And that's going to happen next semester
to get into this and to talk in more
detail about these catalytic reactions.
Notice that this is exactly
the kind of thing, uh, uh,
Sharpless was talking about,
if you could find a way of
lowering one of these barriers,
then the catalytic cycle would work.
He was saying,
remember that it was democratic,
that all the steps as you go around
the cycle have to be at the same,
go at the same rate or
else everything stops up,
stops and waits before it tries
to get over some big step.
So you have to have all the steps be fast.
And that's why he was saying that the,
that, that the dice approachable
ethylamine helped the, uh,
formation of a members all well.
So we've been doing organic
chemistry this semester. Uh,
some people might doubt that.
There'll be no doubt next semester that
everyone will agree that what we do is
organic chemistry.
We're going to talk about the chemistry
of functional groups and sugars and
amino acids and all carbon eel groups
and esters, all of these things.
Uh, but there's a reason that it's
been a little different this semester.
We've talked mostly about physical,
organic chemistry and the reason is
because of where I came from that I did my
phd.
And in fact I took a course
as an undergraduate with
Paul Bartlett at Harvard.
And as you've seen from our common
ancestry that he was a physical organic
chemistry. More interested in how
reactions work than in what you can make.
Okay.
So there's this book that came out in
1939 went through at least three additions
I have, I have the second
and third additions here,
which is called the nature
of the chemical bond.
And this was a fabulously
influential book,
even if it is the one that
said it was 126 kilocalories,
promoted to take carbon away from
graphite when we know it's 171.
Uh,
so Pauling was arguably the
most influential chemist of the,
of the 20th century. He
got two Nobel Prizes, uh,
[inaudible] I think that was
really too
much.
But this tennis you facts and
recipes and does very little thought
intellectual and home to look,
uh, um, can,
she was sort of the continuum.
Okay. So that's what we've been doing
the first semester is this kind of thing.
Thinking about the chemical bond.
We started with wandering with Newton,
whether there was an atomic force law
and then we look to see if we could see
bonds or feel them.
And then we tried to understand bonding
and reactivity through the Schrodinger
equation,
which most people believe
is the fundamental way to
understand things properly.
And then we learned how chemists
learned to treasure the molecular model.
Things like this, right? That turned
out to be really, really useful tools,
right?
Composition,
constitution configuration
and con formation.
And finally energy.
So I hope that we've,
this semester,
if we haven't done as much
organic chemistry as some
people would care for that
at least we've raised
some big questions like
how does science know things,
right?
Or compared to what,
those are the really big questions,
but even if we're only focusing on
the specific content of the course,
interested in bonds here.
Two questions for you to think about.
We're chemical bonds discovered
or where they invented.
To what extent are chemical bonds real
or to what extent are they a figment of a
chemist imagination?
This is the kind of thing we've
been aiming at all semester,
so you should be in a position to think
about this now or would we even have
chemical bonds without our own chemical
forebearers so we've looked at how the
idea of bonds and these different
properties of bonds developed,
but suppose chemistry was developing
in some other solar system,
right?
What would happen there?
Suppose people discovered the Schrodinger
equation before they had the idea of
bonds.
Would bonds have been necessary?
Is Chemistry going to evolve such that
all you need do is put stuff into a
computer, solve quantum
mechanics and forget about bonds.
Okay.
The answers to these questions aren't
obvious, but there are good ones to think.
So, uh, this is the end
and good luck on the final.
Are you fired up?
You're ready to go?
Good.
Thanks.